Stars, galaxy, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man, we're wings, is such a wonder thing.
We hide to solve, come see, come take your place.
Beeping soon for...
Cassiopean fighters, shooting.
Mega command immediately.
Do we do?
Pro.
This is Bluebird.
Cassiopean fighter ships, quest instructions.
Install for time.
Fire warning shots if necessary.
Only a warning.
No encounter, understand, no hostility.
Stay in contact, report regularly.
Get me General Grouchley at once.
Culp!
Two of your fighter craft are at this moment attacking our cruiser Bluebird
on routine patrol off Pegasus.
Order your ships to cease firing and withdraw instantly, General.
Out.
You idiots!
What are you doing?
Will you cut that out immediately?
Come back here quick!
As if the sky of Pegasus were cluttered with Sunday spacecraft.
I know, but calm down.
No point getting too worked up.
That's easy to say.
I won't have my cruise ships shot out like wild ducks.
My orders are very precise.
At all costs, avoid any complications with Cassiopeia.
These incidents aren't pure chance.
Somebody out there must be behind them.
General Grouchly has his eye on the worlds of Pegasus.
I think he plans to conquer them
and simply tell the Confederation they're his.
We have to stop him.
No, Pierre, out of the question.
Anyway, from Cassiopeia and Sophia,
he controls the galaxies of the Swan, the Lizard,
the Little Bear, and the Dragon.
Quite a large piece of the sky, impossible for us to patrol.
Why, I'm convinced that our only tactic must be one of persuasion.
He mustn't feel threatened.
Persuasion, but how do I translate that into any strategic policy that makes sense?
By maintaining a discreet presence in the region of Pegasus.
Avoiding any provocation, waiting for the right time.
Meanwhile, we can intensify our surveillance and forces,
especially in that other vulnerable region, the border around Andromedus.
Presence, right here.
The Pegasus area, don't make waves.
Wait for the right moment.
Got that?
Time's on our side.
Now listen, there is work to do in Andromedus, okay?
Here are my orders.
Interstellar cruising ship Nautilus arriving from Cassiopeia.
Light is on schedule.
Light is ship.
You have more ships like her?
Any problems about that?
Gentlemen, you will take your places.
What's that?
Dear sir, I am so sorry to say that.
Well, distinguished delegate,
the opulence of the craft that has come to take you,
the government of Cassiopeia hold its illustrious representative in highest esteem.
Got it, you got it.
And so, you are taking leave of us?
Quite so, madam. Just that.
Returning home for a much-needed vacation.
The council can assure the distinguished delegate he will be missed, especially if any decisions are to be taken.
Happily, the confederation faces no problems at present.
I know, gentlemen, that you will unanimously wish to express the confederation's very best wishes to the people of Cassiopeia,
and especially to its eminent and distinguished general.
The general, our beloved leader, will be touched.
Truly touched?
I'm off to a bad start.
Quite a show. Couldn't do better for a royal prince.
That was in the chapter entitled, How to Impress the Other Side.
I must say, they didn't spare any expense.
General, then make it quick.
Sure, well, how did it go?
They were impressed beyond our greatest expectations.
I knew they would be.
It truly is a magnificent spaceship, General.
Yes, it's not barely waiting until my next one.
Now, what are your orders? What's next?
Our objective's green planet, the far side of Andromeda, an ideal strategic position for us.
Oxygen in the atmosphere, luxuriance, vegetation, your ship has 800, begin to understand, 800 men is an army.
800?
That's what I said. Soldiers and technicians with enough building material to destruct advanced base.
Once the base is established, we send in our special intervention force. You get it?
Then, Chief, the big gate is almost here.
Exactly. You must follow my orders precisely, understand?
Yes, Chief. Quite so, Chief. Perfectly, Chief.
This time, you're going to be satisfied, son.
An observation mission in the outer regions of Andromeda.
How's that?
Right now, it's pretty quiet out there.
For how long, we don't know.
You will use a craft like the one you trained on.
It should be familiar dragonfly type, but with only one other crew member.
Am I allowed to choose who it is, Colonel?
Certainly, you may choose anyone.
It's a tough decision.
It isn't easy.
Making a choice like this takes plenty of thought.
I'll take him, okay?
Kind of a drag, this mission.
I mean, with nothing really happening.
Well, that's how it is.
It's a strictly routine mission. We can't always count on a lot of enemy action like that time with those giant lizards
Look, there's a small planet there. Let's have a better look at it. Green planet. I feel like they're all around back
Let's go down. Our job's not having a good time. Hey, Lieutenant, have you lost your sense of humor? Take it easy
You see that? Down? Yes, but first we contact Omega. What? You stay with the ship, okay?
I'll go investigate the forest regions. Nice walk. Keep in contact. Here to have a good time. Streaming. Take a look.
like a sports field yeah joining you down to a sparring pot something funny
about this place feel a little giddy you okay piero can't see you but I keep
getting lost here no matter what keep in contact okay okay well have you
awakened again that's what don't get it said that
auger is that you slugger that you just spoke answer me okay auger can you hear
me yes indeed you've been going around in circles well convinced no need to look
any farther it's me who's talking to you me the forest king sovereign ruler over this planet do
you want oh i won't hurt you we've been watching you since you arrived you love nature and if those
others like you had felt the same way we would have welcomed you all here all you men on the
spaceship yes that's right the spaceship or more exactly the spaceships wait a minute just exactly
what happened i mean what have you done patience my own friend i will tell you it all began when
A giant spaceship landed in the Logan.
Bacon, I do not agree with him at all.
A truly magnificent place, he calls this.
All I see is greenery, flowers, trees.
Fooey!
Magnificent in that, I ask you.
It's horrible.
Listen, build roads as quickly as possible.
I want you to carry out a reconnaissance mission in the forest.
All right.
The radio.
A message came.
Our troops were under attack.
You say?
Reinforcements fall into a trap since they've left.
They going crazy?
Chief Counsel!
Still no word.
Can't understand it.
Go and see for yourself. You are the officer in charge.
You were in command.
I know.
Second, second.
See that the morale of the troops is sinking. Very well.
Try a little long-range artillery barrage. It'll soften them up.
But, sir, we can't do that. Our men are still there.
We can't take a risk of killing our own soldiers.
Of course not. Of course not. Well, then, good luck.
Those soldiers, too, in turn, walked into our trap.
See here. They're all sick.
Yes, there were some casualties in the battle, on their side as well as ours.
You must realize we're not willing to let ourselves be massacred.
We are determined to defend our right to life, to live our lives, not yours.
And what can I do? Talk to them? What do you want?
Patience, young man. You haven't heard the whole story.
I suppose that just before the spacecraft exploded, there must have been some signal sent back to their home planet.
Because a short time later...
For this, I'm going to burn this planet to the ground, I'll crush it, I'll destroy it, and every living thing on it.
Yes, but first I want to know who they are to destroy that wonderful space and the best one I ever had.
So, once more, the same thing happened.
But these were even worse than the others at the Supreme Chief for me.
Listen here.
I don't know who you're dealing with, I guess.
I'm an exalted leader of Katyopea.
That's all.
I don't know you, all of you.
Don't you think you've caused enough trouble already?
This planet to smithereens.
It's all that my sin.
I'm going to order.
This is Salamander.
This is Salamander awaiting orders.
This is your general.
I order an immediate blowing up.
I'm sorry, of course you're funny.
Before has anyone...
Prepare to bring about your own destruction.
You will now order your men to leave their ship.
Come into the forest.
It is for their own good.
Go, go.
It's for their own...
Soon as everyone is off the ship, we blow it up.
What can I do?
For centuries, our ancestors have tried to live in harmony with you, the race of men.
We gave you fresh, pure air, beauty, life itself.
And what have you always done?
You have mistreated us.
Cut us down.
Venerable old trees, many centuries old, were not spared.
They were mutilated, exterminated, and all in the name of what you call proud.
Humble flowers knew no pity.
You prefer them dead in vases, thus shattering a universe of light and energy.
They too were living creatures, worthy of respect and love.
But you never saw that.
You know only envy and hate and a rage to destroy.
For centuries we have lived on this planet in peace.
But if we have to fight you, we have our weapons.
Perfumes to make you sleep.
Vibrations that can burst your eardrums.
mastery over fire. We are not warlike. We prefer to have you as friends. But you must give us a
solemn promise never to come back here again. We don't want men here. Majesty, I'm not in charge.
I don't have the power to grant your request. Then go. Speak to your leaders. Tell them my
condition. Yes, not so loud. No need to shout. I'm fine. Don't worry. Calm down. Everything's
all right. I have a lot of things to tell you. It was lucky that I listened to Omega. They said
to stay aboard and wait when I said you didn't answer.
If you'd left the ship, it could have been serious.
Here is where it all started.
You'll see, can't do anything.
Prisoners set forth in the charter
of the Omegan Intergalactic Confederation.
All life is to be respected, whatever form it may take,
and any desire for independence will be honored.
My government authorizes mandatory action
in agreement with majority decision.
In a solemn and irrevocable agreement,
we intend to enforce respect for the green planet.
A lot of pretty words, all that.
And we hereby guarantee that no member of our Confederation will ever return here.
No more talk like that.
We made a solemn undertaking to obtain your release, General. You know that.
I have entered into no agreement. We're not bound by that at all.
You do as you like.
Agreement was voted on by the Confederation, and you are a member, General.
We did not participate in the vote.
Yes, but that's only a technicality.
May I remind you, General, it was because your representative chose to go on vacation
that you were not represented in the debate leading to a vote.
And that vote in favor of the motion, General, gives you no alternative.
Should you make an attack on the planet,
you will have to confront the entire Omega fleet, General.
Now will you please go on to the ship and take you home?